« Juge, je veux vous dire quelque chose. Je veux vous dire quelque chose.
Je vous ai observée
et vous n'êtes pas hypocrite.
Vous traitez tout le monde de la même manière. »
C'est une prostituée transgenre qui m'a dit cela.
Avant que j'arrive au tribunal,
elle avait viré son avocat commis d'office,
insulté l'officier de justice
et crié à la personne assise à côté d'elle :
« Je sais pas ce que tu regardes. Je suis plus jolie que ta copine. »
(Rires)
Elle m'a dit cela
après que j'ai dit son nom masculin assez bas
pour qu'on l'entende à l'enregistrement
mais que j'ai dit son nom féminin assez fort
pour qu'elle puisse descendre l'allée centrale vers le banc des avocats
avec dignité.
C'est la justice procédurale, ou l'équité procédurale,
sous son meilleur jour.
Je suis la fille d'un éboueur afro-américain,
né à Harlem
et qui passait ses étés dans le Sud ségrégué.
Soy la hija de una peluquera dominicana.
Je fais ça pour m'assurer d'avoir encore votre attention.
(Rires)
Je suis la fille d'une esthéticienne dominicaine
qui est venue dans ce pays pour offrir une meilleure vie à ses futurs enfants.
Mes parents m'ont appris
à traiter tous ceux que je rencontre avec respect et dignité,
peu importe leur apparence, leurs vêtements,
ou leur façon de parler.
Les principes d'équité
m'ont été inculqués très jeune,
et, à mon insu, sont devenus la leçon la plus importante
que j'ai apportée avec moi au tribunal municipal de Newark.
Puisque j'ai été traînée hors du terrain de jeu à 10 ans,
pour agir comme traductrice pour des membres de ma famille
qui s'apprêtaient à immigrer aux États-Unis,
je comprends combien il peut être intimidant pour quelqu'un, un novice,
de naviguer dans un système gouvernemental.
Chaque jour à travers l'Amérique et à travers le monde,
les gens interagissent avec nos tribunaux.
C'est un endroit inconnu, intimidant
et souvent hostile à leur égard.
Ils sont déconcertés par la nature de l'accusation,
contrariés par leurs confrontations avec la police
et font face à des conséquences pouvant influencer leurs relations,
leurs finances et même leur liberté.
Laissez-moi vous dépeindre
ce que c'est pour une personne moyenne qui entre dans nos tribunaux.
Tout d'abord, la fouille de la sécurité du tribunal les agace.
Ils finissent par passer la sécurité, marchent dans le bâtiment,
posent la même question à différentes personnes
et obtiennent différentes réponses.
Quand ils arrivent enfin là où ils devaient aller,
les choses empirent quand ils entrent dans le tribunal.
Que penseriez-vous si je vous disais
que vous pouvez améliorer l'expérience judiciaire des gens,
faire qu'ils respectent davantage la loi
et les ordres de la cour,
tout en renforçant la confiance du public
envers le système judiciaire
avec une idée simple ?
Cette idée simple est la justice procédurale.
C'est un concept qui dit
que si les gens se sentent traités de façon équitable,
avec dignité et respect,
ils obéiront à la loi.
C'est ce qu'a découvert le professeur de Yale Tom Tyler,
au début de ses recherches, dans les années 70,
sur pourquoi les gens obéissent à la loi.
Il a découvert que si les gens voyaient le système judiciaire
comme une autorité légitime pouvant imposer des règles et lois,
les gens les suivraient.
Sa recherche a conclu
que les gens seraient satisfaits
des décisions du juge,
même quand il statuait contre eux,
s'ils avaient l'impression d'avoir été traités équitablement,
avec dignité et respect.
Avec quoi commence cette impression d'équité ?
Elle commence par la façon dont les juges parlent aux gens présents en cour.
Être juge,
c'est parfois comme avoir un siège réservé
dans une télé-réalité tragique
qui n'a ni pauses publicitaires
ni spécial de fin de saison.
C'est vrai.
Des gens se présentent devant moi
menottés, en sevrage de drogue, déprimés, affamés
et mentalement malades.
Quand j'ai vu que leur besoin d'obtenir de l'aide
était plus important que ma peur de paraître vulnérable au tribunal,
j'ai réalisé qu'il fallait que je fasse quelque chose,
mais aussi que je pouvais faire quelque chose.
La bonne nouvelle est que les principes de justice procédurale sont faciles
et peuvent être implémentés dès demain.
Encore mieux : cela peut être fait sans frais.
(Rires)
Le premier principe est la voix.
Donnez aux gens l'opportunité de parler,
même lorsque vous n'allez pas les laisser parler.
Expliquez-le.
« Je ne vais pas vous laisser parler tout de suite.
Vous n'avez pas d'avocat.
Je ne veux pas que vous disiez quoi que ce soit vous faisant du tort. »
Assigner des dissertations aux prévenus
est une formidable façon de leur donner une voix.
J'ai récemment donné une dissertation à un étudiant de 18 ans.
Il déplorait son accusation
de consommation d'alcool avant l'âge légal.
Alors qu'il lisait sa dissertation,
sa voix se brisant et ses mains tremblant,
il a dit être inquiet d'être devenu un alcoolique comme sa mère
qui était morte quelques mois auparavant d'une maladie du foie liée à l'alcool.
Assigner une lettre à mon père, une lettre à mon fils,
« Si j'avais su ce que je sais maintenant... »
« Si je croyais une chose positive à mon sujet,
en quoi ma vie serait-elle différente ? »
donne à la personne l'opportunité d'être introspective,
d'aller à l'intérieur,
où se trouvent toutes les réponses.
Mais cela lui donne aussi une opportunité
de partager avec le tribunal
quelque chose allant au-delà de son casier judiciaire
et des accusations.
Le principe suivant est la neutralité.
Pour améliorer la confiance du public envers le système judiciaire,
la neutralité est primordiale.
Le juge ne peut pas être perçu comme favorisant un côté plus que l'autre.
Le juge doit prendre une décision consciente de ne pas dire :
« mon officier », « mon procureur », « mon avocat de la défense ».
C'est complexe quand nous travaillons dans des environnements
où des gens sont assignés à vos tribunaux,
toujours les mêmes personnes.
Quand je pense à la neutralité,
je me souviens de quand j'étais une jeune diplômée en droit à Rutgers
et tout juste nommée procureur,
j'ai rejoint l'arbitrage et ai été saluée par deux hommes aux cheveux gris
qui blaguaient au sujet de leur dernière partie de golf ensemble
et prévoyaient leurs prochaines sorties.
Je savais que ce tribunal ne pouvait pas être équitable.
Le principe suivant est la compréhension.
Il est crucial que les participants comprennent le processus,
ses conséquences
et les attentes à leur égard.
J'aime dire que le jargon juridique est la langue parlée pour créer la confusion.
(Rires)
J'ai conscience que parmi les gens se présentant devant moi,
beaucoup sont très peu éduqués
et l'anglais est souvent leur deuxième langue.
Je parle donc un anglais simple au tribunal.
Un très bon exemple est lorsque j'étais une jeune juge --
je veux dire une juge plus jeune.
(Rires)
Quand j'étais plus jeune, un juge plus âgé est venu,
m'a donné un texte et m'a dit :
« Si tu soupçonnes un problème de santé mentale,
pose ces questions et tu auras ton évaluation. »
La première fois que j'ai vu quelqu'un
semblant avoir des problèmes de santé mentale,
j'ai cherché ce texte et j'ai posé les questions.
« Monsieur, prenez-vous des psycho -- hum, psycho --
des médicaments psychotropes ? »
« Non. »
« Monsieur, avez-vous déjà été suivi par un psychiatre ? »
Mais il était évident que cette personne souffrait de maladie mentale.
Un jour, frustrée, j'ai décidé de jeter ce texte et de poser une question.
« Prenez-vous des médicaments pour éclaircir votre esprit ? »
« Je prends de l'Haldol pour ma schizophrénie
et du Xanax pour mon anxiété. »
La question fonctionne même quand elle ne fonctionne pas.
« Prenez-vous des médicaments pour éclaircir votre esprit ? »
« Je ne prends pas de médicaments pour m'éclaircir l'esprit
mais pour faire taire les voix dans ma tête,
mon esprit va bien. »
(Rires)
Une fois que les gens comprennent la question,
ils peuvent offrir des informations utiles
permettant au tribunal de prendre des décisions sensées
au sujet des dossiers qui lui sont présentés.
Le dernier principe est le respect,
sans lequel aucun des autre principes ne peut fonctionner.
Le respect peut être simplement :
« Bonjour Monsieur », « Bonjour Madame ».
C'est regarder dans les yeux la personne se tenant face à vous,
en particulier quand vous les condamnez.
C'est quand je dis : « Comment allez-vous ?
Et que vous arrive-t-il ? »
Pas pour les saluer,
mais en tant que personne vraiment intéressée par la réponse.
Le respect, c'est la différence entre :
« Madame, avez-vous des difficultés
à comprendre les informations dans les papiers ? »
et « Vous savez lire et écrire, n'est-ce pas ? »
quand vous avez remarqué un problème d'alphabétisation.
Ce qui est bien avec le respect, c'est que c'est contagieux.
Les gens vous voient être respectueux envers les autres
et ils imputent ce respect à eux-mêmes.
C'est ce que la prostituée transgenre me disait.
Je vous juge autant que vous pensez être en train de me juger.
Je ne vous dis pas ce que je pense,
je parle de mon expérience,
utilisant la justice procédurale
pour changer la culture de mon palais de justice
et de mon tribunal.
Après avoir passé sept mois confortables
en tant que juge pour la circulation,
on m'a informée que j'étais mutée dans un tribunal pénal -
le tribunal pénal « Part Two ».
Je veux que vous compreniez
que ce n'était pas une bonne nouvelle.
(Rires)
Vraiment pas.
Part Two était réputé comme le pire tribunal de la ville,
certains diraient même de l'État.
C'était un tribunal urbain typique avec une justice de porte-tambour :
l'habituelle lignée de petits déliquants,
les cibles faciles,
la prostituée toxicomane,
le sans-abri un peu dérangé
avec des contraventions pour trouble de l'ordre public,
le petit trafiquant de drogues ayant arrêté le lycée
et le jeune malavisé --
ces gens purgeant une peine à perpétuité,
par portions de 30 jours.
Heureusement, la ville de Newark a décidé que ses habitants méritaient mieux
et est devenu partenaire du Centre d'innovation judiciaire,
du système judiciaire du New Jersey
pour créer les Solutions communautaires de Newark,
un programme judiciaire communautaire
offrant des sanctions alternatives.
Cela signifie qu'un juge peut maintenant
condamner un prévenu à une peine avec assistance.
Un prévenu qui serait condamné à une peine de prison
peut avoir de l'encadrement individuel,
des thérapies de groupe et de la restitution communautaire,
qui est le terme désignant le travail communautaire.
Le seul problème est que ce merveilleux programme
arrivait à Newark. Où allait-il avoir lieu ?
Dans le tribunal pénal Part Two.
Les mentalités étaient très négatives.
La raison pour laquelle les mentalités étaient mauvaises
était que toute personne y étant envoyée
comprenait qu'elle y était envoyée par punition.
Les officiers faisant parfois face à des actions disciplinaires,
le défenseur public et le procureur
avaient l'impression de faire un roulement de sentences de 30 jours de prison,
les juges savaient que l'on se moquait d'eux
comme dans une sororité ou fraternité universitaire.
On m'a dit qu'un avocat qui travaillait là-bas
parlait des prévenus comme de « la lie de la société »
puis devait les représenter.
J'entendais des choses comme :
« Comment peux-tu travailler avec ces gens ? Ils sont si obscènes.
Tu es juge, pas travailleuse sociale. »
La réalité est qu'en tant que société, nous criminalisons les problèmes sociaux,
envoyons les gens voir un juge et lui disons d'y faire quelque chose.
J'ai décidé de montrer l'exemple.
Ma première percée dans l'approche est venue quand un homme de 60 ans
s'est présenté devant moi, menotté.
Il baissait la tête
et son corps présentait des signes de sevrage de drogue.
Je lui ai demandé depuis combien de temps il se droguait, il a dit : « 30 ans. »
Je lui ai demandé s'il avait des enfants.
Il a dit : « Ouais, j'ai un fils de 32 ans. »
J'ai dit : « Vous n'avez jamais eu la chance
d'être un père pour votre fils à cause de votre addiction. »
Il a commencé à pleurer.
J'ai dit : « Je vais vous laisser rentrer chez vous
et vous reviendrez dans deux semaines.
Quand vous reviendrez, nous vous aiderons avec votre addiction. »
Étonnamment, deux semaines plus tard, il était de retour au tribunal.
Son tour venu, il a dit : « Je suis revenu au tribunal
car vous avez fait preuve de plus d'amour que je n'en ai pour moi-même. »
Et je me suis dit : « Mon dieu, il a entendu de l'amour au tribunal ?
Je pourrais faire ça toute la journée. »
(Rires)
La réalité est que quand le tribunal se comporte différemment,
les gens réagissent différemment.
Le tribunal devient un endroit où vous allez chercher de l'aide,
comme la femme sans-abri et schizophrène de 60 ans
qui était en détresse
et se battait contre les voix dans sa tête,
a déboulé dans le tribunal et a crié : « Juge !
Je suis venue voir comment vous alliez. »
Je suivais son dossier depuis quelques mois,
sa prise de médicaments,
et je venais de clore son dossier deux semaines auparavant.
Ce jour-là, elle avait besoin d'aide
et elle est venue au tribunal.
Après quatre heures où le juge, les officiers de police et employés
ont essayé de la persuader,
elle est montée dans l'ambulance
qui l'emmenait à l'unité de crise
afin qu'elle ait ses médicaments.
Les gens se lient à leur communauté
quand le tribunal change,
comme cet homme d'une cinquantaine d'années
qui m'a dit : « Le service communautaire, c'était dur.
J'ai dû nettoyer le parc plein d'enveloppes d'héroïne vides
et les enfants devaient jouer là. »
En se triturant les mains, il a avoué :
« Juge, j'ai réalisé que c'était de ma faute
car j'allais dans ce parc pour me droguer.
Avant que vous ne m'y envoyiez pour du service communautaire,
je n'avais pas été au parc quand je n'étais pas drogué,
je n'avais jamais remarqué que les enfants jouaient là. »
Tous les toxicomanes au tribunal ont baissé la tête.
Qui pourrait mieux leur enseigner cette leçon ?
Cela aide le tribunal à rétablir sa relation avec la communauté,
comme ce gars d'une vingtaine d'années
ayant eu un entretien d'embauche via un programme du tribunal.
Il a eu un entretien dans une entreprise de nettoyage
et est revenu fier au tribunal :
« Juge, j'ai même travaillé en costume après l'entretien
car je voulais que le mec voit à quel point je voulais ce boulot. »
Voici ce qu'il se passe quand quelqu'un ayant de l'autorité
vous traite avec dignité et respect,
comme cet homme de 40 ans se pavanant le long de l'allée centrale
et qui a dit : « Vous remarquez quelque chose de différent ? »
Quand j'ai levé les yeux,
il me montrait ses nouvelles dents
qu'il a pu obtenir en ayant été recommandé par le programme
et qu'il a pu remplacer ses vieilles dents
qu'il avait perdues après des années d'addiction à l'héroïne.
Quand il regarde dans le miroir,
il voit maintenant quelqu'un méritant d'être sauvé.
J'ai un rêve
et ce rêve est que les juges utilisent ces outils
pour révolutionner les communautés qu'ils servent.
Ces outils ne sont pas des solutions miracles,
mais ils nous ont énormément rapprochés de là où nous voulons aller
et nous voulons aller vers un endroit
où les gens allant au tribunal
croient qu'ils seront traités avec dignité et respect
et sachent que justice y sera rendue.
Imaginez cela, une idée simple.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)